Thank you. Hi everyone.
I'm Jeff [inaudible].
I'm the vice president of global resorts
at Burton and I've had the pleasure of
knowing Kelly Clark for 18 years.
She is absolutely incredible,
whether it's helping us out with a resort
photo shoot or helping us introduce
really young kids to snowboarding and
physical education in elementary schools.
Kelly has always made the time,
whether it no matter what
community she's living in,
she always wants to give back.
Okay.
If you take a look at her career,
it's absolutely incredible.
Spanning 18 years,
five Olympics,
three Olympic medals,
eight u s opened metals
and 14 x games medals.
Now, if you stack her against the top
female athletes, if you look right there,
that 47% wind rate is outstanding,
so 47% of the time she entered a
snowboard competition, she won.
So impressive. If you stack it
against the top male athletes,
once again, you'll see how
impressive that win rate is.
So I'm very honored and excited to
introduce Kelly Clark to you today,
but before I do that,
I want to share one of her winning moments
also
in the history of this event coming out of
riding for Burton snowboards.
This is Kelly. Hello
today, and it was typical Kelly
Clark. She drops in for her first run,
puts down a score of 86.88 the
highest of the day. The other riders,
she's not too far ahead of crop cassoulet.
What did she do on her second round?
She ups it by three points. 89.33 and
I would not be surprised, right? Yeah.
Can we put down a run in the 90s even
though she goes even though victory,
can we put an exclamation point on this?
When you look at the standings tomorrow,
are you doing
and she's doing so right here.
Look at how high she's leading on that
transition right below the big hunting,
keeping a hard edge to get flat bottom.
Absolutely massive.
Carrie did just put it on.
Wow. Ladies and gentlemen, Kelly Clark.
Okay,
thanks for the introduction Jeff.
I'm thanks everybody for coming
and hanging out with us today. Um,
it's a, it's a huge honor
for me to be here. Um,
I'm excited to get the share some
of my life, some of my process. Um,
sports have such a good way of just
illustrating kind of life's principles.
Um, I've been with, um,
with Burton snowboards
for the last 20 years.
This marks my 20th year with the brand,
which is a pretty incredible
relationship I've had with them.
I've had a abnormally
long snowboard career. Um,
I'm technically very old to be
a pro snowboarder at 35. Um,
so it's, uh, it's been really fun though.
I've really learned everything that
I've learned to kind of develop into the
person that I am through snowboarding.
They have kind of a rubber meets
the road type of ability to,
to show you what you're,
what you're capable of and
show you what you built. Um,
I always say I trained 30 seconds,
uh,
high train for years for 32nd half pipe
run. So there's a lot that goes into the,
behind the scenes that people don't see
any snowboarder's in here.
Any, any skiers in here? A, okay.
You guys can stay. We still like you.
I was up in Tahoe last week and um,
there's a lot better snow than
there has been the last few years,
so it should be a really fun winter.
Um, I grew up in Vermont. Um,
I live in Sacramento currently and I
started snowboarding when I was seven.
It was the first year was even
allowed at my home resort. Um, 1990.
I always say that I started
snowboarding before it was cool. Um,
there was no such thing as the winter
x games and it was long before it ever
became an Olympic sport. And
honestly, I never wanted to compete.
It was really,
uh,
I actually was a ski racer and I
skipped enough ski racing practice to,
uh,
have my parents stopped paying for that
just so I could snowboard all the time.
And I never wanted,
I never want it to compete because
the kind of ski racing vibe was really
cutthroat and competitive. And as a young
kid I did, it just didn't appeal to me.
And I had the opportunity to go to the
high school where it was essentially a,
a private school where I could go to
school half day and snowboard half day.
And that sounded like a
pretty good gig to me.
And I just knew I wanted to spend more
days on the hill and to be able to go to
this school I had to compete.
So I thought, okay, I'll,
I'll get in the competition.
That was when I was 14 years old and I
actually just kind of fell in love with
him. It was, um, I was
halfway decent at it,
which was great and I really enjoyed it.
And then I remember you don't often think
you make big decisions when you're 14
years old.
It was 1998 and it was the first year
that snowboarding became an Olympic sport.
And I remember I had
recorded it on a VHS tape.
Anybody VHS tapes,
I probably like recorded over an episode
of friends or something. But I, uh,
had recorded the Olympics snowboarding's
debut and I remember everything about
that day. I remember where I was,
I remember what I was wearing,
I remember what the weather was like and,
and I saw snowboarding
become an Olympic sport.
And I knew right then and there that
this was a dream that I wanted to give my
life to. And, um,
four years later I found myself
and my first Olympics in 2002, um,
and then followed it up with
Italy in Torino, Vancouver, Sochi,
Russia. And then my last
Olympics was in Korea. Um,
so over 16 years,
uh,
I've had the privilege of representing
my country five different times. And, uh,
I have one last draw all that.
I've had a wide range of
Olympic experiences. Um,
and it's been fun to kind
of pull on those and,
and see the personal growth
growth in my life. Um,
you know, through snowboarding
I've learned to be successful,
so to speak.
I've learned a great deal about failure,
but more so than anything I've
learned to enjoy what I do.
And that's what I want to talk about
today. How do we not only be successful,
but how do you actually thrive in the
environment that you're in? And you know,
I live in a performance culture
every weekend in the winter.
I go out there and see what I built
and see if I have what it takes.
But you don't have to be an Olympian to
find yourselves living in a performance
culture. Um, you know,
we only have to pick up our phones to
have a glance at social media and start
comparing ourselves to one another.
It's,
it's where we find ourselves living a
lot of the time is in this performance
world. Um, but the,
the good news is,
is just because we live in this culture,
it doesn't mean that culture
gets to live with inside of us.
So there's a few things that I want to
touch on today that have really helped me
learn to thrive in that environment
and that performance world.
And I'm just going to hit on those and
I'm going to tell a few stories to kind
of illustrate that.
Does that sound good?
So we talk about performance, culture. Um,
but what does that actually
mean in the performance world?
It says,
I wonder if I'm enough.
I will sacrifice respect
and honor to get ahead.
I will work for everything and I
will compete to earn what I deserve.
And this is the big thing.
External success is the only thing
that matters and it performance world.
So those are the things,
that's the place we find ourselves in.
It seems pretty extreme
when I lifted out like that,
but those are the things that's,
that's the race we find
ourselves in a lot of the time.
And I'm just going to touch on
thriving here for a minute to, um,
how many of you guys have succulence at
home? Anybody proud? Succulent owner?
Would you say they're thriving or our IP?
Succulence maybe rip succulents.
Huh? That happens. Um,
you know,
you can be successful and not be thriving,
but it's hard to be thriving
and not feel successful.
And it only takes us looking at our house
plants to see if something's driving.
And usually when something's
driving it means that it's growing.
And that's honestly what
it means to thrive. If
something's growing, we say, oh,
we put that plan right
where it needed to be.
We gave it the right amount of water.
It's in the right environment.
And when it grows, that's, that's what
we say. Hey, it's my plants are thriving.
I don't know how many green thumbs
we have in here, but I know, um,
you often think you're
thriving when you're winning.
You think you're thriving
when you're successful. Um,
but as I'll kind of dive into this,
success just looks like growth and that's
what we need to be doing in our lives
and that's, that's what we need
to be putting in the win column.
So the few things that I,
I want to bring up that I've really
found in my career that have helped me be
successful and thrive and
enjoy what I do. Um, honestly,
it all starts with our identity.
It's so easy to get a sense of self worth
and a sense of significance wrapped up
in our performance. Um, in
sports we see it the most.
We see the roughest transitions when
people want athletes retire because they
get so much of their self worth
and their performance. And it's,
it's a natural thing to do. That's how
we identify each other. When we meet,
when we meet people who say, Oh, who are
you and what do you do? You know, it's,
it's, um, it's very easy to find
yourself operating in that place.
But I'd like to propose that success
isn't what we're looking for.
I think we're looking for a deep sense
of significance and I think we try to
fill that with success
and with performance.
I know I've done that a ton in my career.
When your self worth is a
tied to your performance,
we can't take risks. Um, think about it.
If I'm in a snowboard contest and,
um,
I'll actually use an example from,
from Russia heading
into the 2014 Olympics.
I was a heavy gold medal favorite.
Um, I was supposed to perform well.
That was, uh, I was probably,
if I looked back at my career,
that was probably kind of the
prime time of my snowboard career.
And I was 30 years old and it was my
fourth Olympics. I had kind of all the,
all the bugs out of my system.
I was pretty comfortable knowing what
I wanted to accomplish that time.
And uh,
when we showed up for the event,
it was a 55 degrees and if
anybody knows what snow does,
when it's 55 degrees, it becomes
very challenging. And, um,
I took my first run at a 1:00 PM and three
rounds of competition happened before
my final run, which was around 9:00 PM.
And if you can imagine in those terms,
the pipe deteriorated.
I'm in epic fashion.
When I showed up for finals, uh, I moved,
I remember it took five runs in
practice for finals and I moved my 10 83
different times and I
couldn't get it to work.
I fell five runs in a row
in my practice for finals.
And now that doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to a fall in the contest,
but especially at the Olympics like you
want, you want your practice to go well,
it's going to kind of set the tone
for your performance that evening.
And I remember I went down
and I saw a sea of team USA.
People kind of staring at me knowing
that the train had completely fallen off
the tracks. And I saw my
sports psychologist and I
looked at her and I said,
hey,
you know what?
I actually need to go and have a good
cry and then I think I'm going to be
ready.
Um,
I think if your significance and your
personal view is tied to your performance,
you really can't take those
risks that you need to.
And because everything in life
is an opportunity or a threat.
And I needed to look at that
moment as an opportunity.
And in a performance world,
we're at our worst when we're
afraid we ever seen somebody,
uh, hardest store. If someone
drowning, you know, when,
when somebody goes to save them,
they actually tried to drown the
person that's trying to save them.
We are at our worst when we are,
when we're afraid.
And I was looking at these next two
runs in the Olympics. I had waited,
um, for years. I had spent an
entire lifetime since I was 14,
investing in this dream and it's
going as bad as it possibly can go.
Um, after my ugly cry, I went
to the top and I said, okay,
this is an opportunity to overcome
a bad situation. And uh, you know,
what happened?
My next run I went and um,
I landed my 10 for the
first time that night,
but took off early on my seven and I hit
the deck and I like to call it like a
reverse Taco.
If you can imagine that.
I bounced to the flat reverse
Taco and I fell an epic fashion.
Um, and I was probably more prepared
for first run fall than a poor practice.
I knew even though I'd
fallen six runs in a row,
I still had an opportunity if I was so
caught up in the expectation of being the
gold mental favorite,
if I was so caught up in maintaining my
reputation and what people thought and
what I even demanded of myself,
I would not be in an opportunity
that would be in a threat.
And in a performance world,
we need to be at our best. Um,
I went back to the top, I saw
my coach and uh, you know,
we had been through this scenario a
lot of times it was first run falls,
it happens. I, this last week I
was counting up a bunch of my, um,
my competition bibs and I have over 190.
And so those first run falls,
it's happened a few times and I went
back up and um, to be quite honest,
it was the, it was the hardest thing that
I ever did. But I told my coach, Hey,
what an opportunity. Six runs.
I've fallen consecutively.
I was the last person to go over the
entire event cause I'd qualified first for
finals.
So we run in reverse order and I dropped
in and I landed a run and it was good
enough to put me on the Olympic podium
and I'd fallen six runs in a row,
only Atlanta my seventh,
when it mattered most.
And I was so proud of my performance.
It wasn't necessarily
my best snowboarding.
I've still boarded a lot better than that.
But to overcome that personally
in that situation, um,
I was really able to,
to those situations,
they reveal where your identity is.
When you look to what you're,
what you're responding to around you
and how you're gonna react in those
situations. We need to be our
best and that sort of outlook,
looking at things as an opportunity is
really a big way to do that. Hey guys,
doing you off the quiet?
Everybody good? Um,
so the next thing I want to touch on,
um,
is we need to have a
healthy idea of success.
If you want to thrive in
a performance culture,
that's something that you're
going to have to work out.
What does success look like to you?
Um, you know, honestly, that's what I,
that's what I set out to do with my book.
Um,
I wanted to help people define
success in a healthy way. Um,
as you can gather,
my idea of success doesn't necessarily
isn't confined to just winning.
If I were to say what my
personal definition of it is,
I want to be able to look back at my
journey and say I was really faithful with
the opportunities that were in front
of me and I didn't let one go by.
And I also asked myself if I was growing,
if those two things are
happening in my life,
if I made the most of my
opportunities and I had some,
some measure of growth,
honestly that's,
that's more successful than
you could ever hope to be. Um,
and the last,
the last thing on my little mini list
here that I want to set you guys up with
is, you know, after 20
years of snowboarding,
I've come to the conclusion that
if your dream only includes you,
it's too small of a dream.
Um, I found that were,
were really thriving in life when other
people are involved. Um, you know,
whatever culture you live in,
whatever dream you're building,
if you're the only one in it,
it's just too small of a dream.
If you build your, if you build
yourself, your influence will go away.
When you're no longer performing,
you yourself.
If you only build yourself.
We have to figure out how to build
things that will outlast our ability to
perform.
So a few of the just kind of
fundamental building blocks,
we've got to work out that identity piece.
Uh,
we have to develop a healthy idea of
success and we have to find value and
building others.
But the most important thing that I've
learned throughout my career has really
helped me thrive. Um, I've learned to,
to look at the things that no one sees
and treat them as more valuable than the
things that everyone sees. Um, if
it sounds strange and unfamiliar,
it's because it is. It's not, it's
not natural. It's not our Goto,
but the,
the world inside of me and the personal
victories and the winds that, um,
aren't on TV that nobody beyond my
friends and family will ever see.
Um,
those are the things that I value much
more than any placement than any metal
that I could win.
The world inside of you has to be more
important than the world around you.
If you ever find yourself,
um,
if you ever feel like life is
happening to you, uh, it's a pretty,
pretty good indication that you're
not living from a value set and making
decisions. You're not living
intentionally. You're living reactionary.
And, um, we really have to work on
this inner world, this idea of success,
this identity stuff are our big
picture and building others.
Um,
and we have to learn to treat the things
that nobody sees is more important than
the ones that are on display.
So there's a,
um,
how many of you guys watched
the Olympics is last year?
Anybody catch the woman's
halfpipe? How's there? Um,
you know,
this is a,
this is the ultimate story of valuing
things that no one sees more than what the
NBC cameras we'll show you.
Um,
I set out to do the
impossible. Last year. Uh,
no woman from the u s had ever made, made
five Winter Olympic teams in any sport.
And, um, you know, um, I've been
the veteran now for, I don't know,
10 years and snowboarding. Uh, uh,
the women that I compete with are quite
literally half my age. If I, I remember,
I believe it was two summers ago,
I was on the podium with two women and
if you added up their ages at literally
equaled mine and I'm not,
I'm 35.
It's like I'm not old.
I didn't think I was old until I look
around and they say the TV shows that I
like aren't funny because they
have live studio audiences. Um,
it's interesting. It happens
quick, but you know, I,
I knew this would be my last,
my last Rodeo. It would be the last
time I got the chance to do this.
And in January I found myself name
until the Olympic team. And um,
it was in mammoth, mammoth
mountain, California,
which was my home resort for a long time.
And it was just a sweet when at that
final Olympic qualifier, now they,
they named the Olympic qualifier
or they named the Olympic team.
Last qualifier is only two weeks
before opening ceremony starts.
So it's not this, you know, you're
on the team for a long time.
There's literally two weeks and I think
the night that you get named to the team,
the team manager is calling you to book
your plane ticket because they need to
pay for it.
And um,
there's a small contest that falls in
between when they named the team and when
we go to the Olympics and it's called
the x games and a lot of people will,
you can look at it two ways and you go
look at it as an opportunity or a threat.
You could say,
hey,
this is a great opportunity to go to
this big event and get ready for the
biggest event. Or I could play
it safe and saying, you know,
I don't want to get hurt. I should
probably protect myself and play it safe,
which is something I've
never been good at.
And best way to get ready for a big
contest is going to a big contest.
And so I go to this event and I'm trying
to get my snowboarding and where it
needs to be. And my first run
is pretty good. I think I'm set,
it's sitting in second or third
place and I'm pushing myself,
trying to get my snowboarding
to where it needs to be.
And in my second run I
go down extremely hard.
I hit the deck again and bounced
to the flat and I actually was,
was pretty okay up until that
point. But when I hit the flat, um,
my left knee was so crumbled,
I was so crumbled in my left knee,
hit my left shoulder and I heard
a loud pop in my left knee.
And I remember sitting there with the
Mega Moe Follow Cam ski guy in my face
with a camera not being able to breathe
because I'd knocked the wind out of
myself thinking I'm pretty
sure I just blew my ACL.
And I'm thinking,
I just made the Olympic team and I don't
think I'm ever even going to get to go.
So I picked myself up.
I go down to the bottom of the pipe and a,
the u s team,
we have all of our doctors and
surgeons on hand and I said, Hey, uh,
I pretty sure I heard a pop.
And I'm pretty sure I just heard my ACL
go and my knee and I can feel there's,
there's fluid in the back of my,
my top of my calf above my boots
filling fluid and my joints beginning to
stiffen up.
And um,
so we go there and x Games has their
team of orthopedic surgeons and on my own
team of Ortho Orthopedic Surgeons and uh,
there's a manual test you can do.
You guys are familiar to kind of see
if you have an end point. So they,
they're doing all the manual tests,
multiple high level orthopedic guys
are all with testing my knee and they,
they think I have an end point.
Like we think you have an ACL but we're
going to have to wait till Monday and
we'll get the MRI and we'll
figure out what's going on.
Monday comes around and um,
the radiologist is looking at the films
after my Mri and they can kind of, um,
they,
they know how to read the films and they
can kind of get an idea of what's going
on in there. So I was asking the guy,
I was like, Hey, do you, do you see a,
you see my ligaments in there? You know,
how's it, how's it look? And he's like,
you know,
I don't know much about your ligaments,
but I do see the tibial plateau fracture
that's clear as day. And I thought,
I'm sorry, what? He's like, yeah,
the fracture and your Tibia. That's,
that's a really clear to see.
I don't know if you have ligaments or not,
but definitely broke your leg.
And uh,
I didn't, I didn't see that coming. I, uh,
I talked to my surgeon that night and I
say, what, what's going on? And he said,
you, you have an ACL, um,
you have a severe bone bruise and
you've cracked your Tibia plateau. Um,
the good news is is it's in an area
where it's not extremely weight bearing,
but you definitely have a
fracture. And, uh, so what,
what does, what does this name,
you know,
what are we looking at now?
We've got maybe a week and a
half until we fly to Korea.
So we get my coach on the phone and we
look at everything and they say, hey,
you know,
we think we can get you through this.
And, uh, he said, here's the plan.
We brace you up with this
giant mechanical leg.
We medially load your knee to create a
little bit of space in your joint and we
load you up on a Wada and Usada
approved anti-inflammatories.
And,
uh,
you have to agree not to
practice up until send me, uh,
qualifiers for the Olympic
Games. And I said, hey, I,
I think, I think we
can do that. Um, but I,
I had to ask my coach, I said, hey,
if you want to send somebody who
perhaps doesn't have a broken leg,
I would give up my spot. I understand.
I understand that. And he said, no,
I would always bet on you,
you know,
and so I have the most
incredible support team. Um,
and I put full faith
and full trust in them.
And I flew to my fifth Olympic Fifth
Olympics with a fractured Tibia.
I remember I was late for my plane,
actually in San Francisco and I was
trying to get to the plane quickly and I
couldn't even run, walk. It was
excruciating. And I'm thinking,
what am I doing?
I got to Korea,
we gradually got me in the gym.
Um,
I didn't practice for the entire event.
I think I took three runs in
the halfpipe before qualifiers,
qualifiers came around and I just barely
snuck in there cause I mean every half
pipes, so different. Um,
and I'm honestly learning to ride with
the mechanical leg sort of brace was very
new and very challenging for
me. Um, and I snuck in there,
they took 12 people in the finals
and I qualified in 11th. You know,
it was not my best snowboarding,
but I made it. Yeah. And um,
I was honestly believe in the dream.
Again, at this point I was thinking, Gosh,
I've overcome so much. I totally, I
totally want that fairy tale ending.
I want that. I want that
metal. I want one more,
kind of just a fairy tale ending.
I wanted to finish well and um,
I can honestly say the day of Finals,
anti-inflammatory pills, uh, adrenaline,
whatever it was,
I can honestly say my injury did
not affect my performance that day.
I,
I rode lights out as the kids
say out of my mind and I rode,
I rode so well. I put down three
runs that were perfect in my mind.
I could have dealt with less
tears and more practice,
but my performance said day, um, it
was as good as it could have been.
I put down some of my best runs
at my fifth Olympic Games and,
um,
I came so far,
overcame so much,
and I was waiting for my final score to
pop up and I didn't see the letter or
the number one,
two or three,
but I saw the number for pop up
and I would remain in fourth. Um,
keeping my Olympic streak alive to never
worse than fourth, which is pretty good.
But a fourth,
uh,
you only get your participation
medal from the Olympics,
which is probably controversial in
itself, just patient metals. Um,
but I didn't get on that podium and
I remember standing there and I had a
microphone put it in my face and in
front of millions and millions of people,
I was asked for a reason why this
didn't work out, what happened, Kelly,
what went wrong.
And I had every opportunity to find a
reason why I actually had a good reason
why I'm I, yeah. Ps, I broke
my leg two weeks ago. Um,
but you know,
what happened?
The world inside of being popped to the
surface and I was able to respect the
people I was competing with.
I was able to respect the
judging and the formats.
I was able to keep my integrity and
keep my honor and the world inside of me
proved to be much bigger. The world
that I was in at that time. Um,
you know,
people always ask me what one
of my Olympic medals, which I,
I brought with me today,
I'll, I'll let you guys all
check them out at the end. Um,
you know, which one of your Olympic
medals means the most to you.
And I've really found that
they're very prestigious,
but it's what they represent that gives
them value and you value things based
off of what they cost you. Um, you know,
some of these metals are more
expensive then, um, perhaps the one,
when I was 18, you know, uh,
I won Olympic gold in Salt Lake City
when I was 18 years old. And it's a,
it's easy being a rookie. No
expectation and pressure. Um,
Russia I would say is probably my favorite
metal because I know what it costs
me. It was so expensive. It
took everything that I had.
You know,
my,
my idea of a fairy tale ending was
one more shot at that Olympic podium,
but I think standing upright in
the face of loss and the face of,
um,
disappointment was perhaps the most
valuable end than I ever could have had.
And that moment was much more costly.
Keeping your integrity costs a lot.
Sometimes you don't find it
and very fun situations often.
Um,
but I'm beginning to see that perhaps I
should view that experience differently
because of the success and the,
when that actually happened on the inside
of me that people wouldn't say wasn't
necessarily successful. No one
knew, knew what I overcame that day.
Um,
you know,
at the end of the event I went,
I went home and I had hundreds of text
messages and voicemails and emails and,
um,
I kind of just blurry eyed,
stared at my phone and there was
one message that popped up that
caught my attention and I think speaks
to the value of what actually happened
that day. It's from one of my, uh,
my longtime manager who I've been with
since I was 15 years old and he had
watched, he'd watched the event, um,
on TV with his son and he wrote me
this email I'm going to read to you.
He said, congratulations on an amazing
finals. If you've taught me one thing,
it's that we're fools to allow the
judgment of others to influence our own
appreciation of performance.
This seems especially true today,
having seen each of your Olympic
runs over your long career.
I can say this with some of your
best work, you started strong. Yes,
strategically contained,
pushed it further in the second
and under the greatest pressure,
crushed it in the third and reminds me
of Turino where you did more for women's
snowboarding than most gold
medal performances combined
your enjoy listening to
Todd Richards commentary about
what he thought about your run.
I saw your interview after
the event with Tina Dixon.
I could see and feel your
frustration and disappointment,
but your maturity and
perspective prevailed and you
showed class and composure
that few athletes could muster.
Benny who is a son who is now 14 was
watching with me and he asked me,
dad, how can she be so calm and nice
after that? I smiled when he asked me
when he asked me that
through five Olympics. Kelly,
you've managed to find so many ways in
addition to winning and metals to inspire
people and we better than they
could have previously imagined.
And as much as I know you want it to
win and I wanted you to win as a parent
would,
it's much more precious and opportunity
to discover a moment of such magnitude.
And as an athlete have such profound
talent and historical significance to
demonstrate the values you embody.
There will be many metals
awarded over these Olympics,
but I know Benny would have
asked me that question,
had you not thrown down the runs you did,
been dealt,
the scores you received and
handled that the way you did.
And in terms of inspiration,
it's moments like that that can make a
huge difference in a kid's life and in
the world. I'm so proud of
you, Kelly, what you've done,
who you are and how you've lived your
life and I've been a privileged to be part
of it. And the effect you have on people
transcends results metals and transcends
snowboarding.
I can't wait to see how you inspire people
outside of the halfpipe whenever that
may be.
And I promise you that I'll support you
in those efforts however I can for as
long as I can.
So we measure success based off of what
color metal we get and we don't always
place a value on things like this.
That was the message that I needed
to hear when I went home. Heartbreak,
heartbroken that day.
Realizing that there's so much
more than just performance.
Um,
it wasn't something everyone saw,
but perhaps it's more valuable than
a million gold medals could ever be.
We have to build things that outlast
our ability. Perform to perform.
Yeah.
My life is a testament
to going after a dream.
We're supposed to go after all that's
in our hearts with an hit all of our
potential. And it's not going to be all
rainbows and butterflies all the time.
There's going to be a lot of hard days,
but it should be enjoyable. I think.
We think everything should
always be fun. And, um,
people are also here what I do
for a living and they say, well,
I must be really fun. And I'm
like, it is really fun. Um,
and a lot of people, especially
professional athletes are
like, why do you do it?
And you're like, it's so fun. Like,
I'm sorry. It's like, spoiler alert.
It's not always going to be fun.
What? It should be enjoyable.
And if you can work out
how to not be defined by what you do,
how to build others up,
how to define success in a healthy way,
and how to value the things that no one
sees more than the things that are on
display.
Um,
you will have a successful career and
there's going to be a lot of growth.
You're going to be thriving and you're
going to be enjoying what you do.
Um, you know, for me
as a, as a snowboarder,
I've had a very long career and I've
had more success than anyone could ever
dream when I was 14.
I've had more success than I
ever began to dream about. Um,
and I'm so thankful and it's
been such a privilege. Um,
and if it was about accomplishing things,
if it was about winning things,
I honestly, I probably should
have stopped a long time ago.
You have to figure out how to
make what you do. More than that,
you have to figure out how to develop
something inside of you that will sustain
you no matter what environment.
And you go into, um, you know,
burnout doesn't come
from too much activity.
If anybody should be burned out,
it should be me.
I've done a million snowboarding contest.
It really comes from unmet expectations.
And so if you can spend time
developing that inner world,
you're going to be able to go into any
world and hit your potential and be your
best and enjoy it and always remember
that if your dream only includes you,
it's just too small of a dream.
Thank you.
I was curious at the beginning,
you said you are training Oise for
basically 30 seconds of a halfpipe run and
I'm curious how you go about sort of
maintaining that mindset of training when
the actual live performance.
It seems like to me it seems like it's
always like so far away and such an
uplifting time.
You know,
I think you need to have an idea of what
you want to accomplish regardless of
what's going on around you. Um,
as I would approach Neil Olympics,
I knew where my snowboarding
was going to need to be.
I think it's easy to get caught
up in looking around to what, um,
my fellow competitors were doing.
Um,
but if you can figure out what
it is you want to accomplish, um,
it's something that you can
work on regardless of what's
going on around you. So
it's, um, you know,
it may look like what we do is
kind of like, oh my goodness,
I just tried this trick today. I think it
took me, I think it took me seven years,
the first land at 10 80.
So it's very much in the scope of what
you want to and no matter what you
accomplish,
and especially in snowboarding,
like you're never the best and there
isn't a day that goes by that I'm not
challenged. And I think that's
what kept me motivated is I,
I enjoyed the challenge.
I enjoyed constantly learning things.
And if I wasn't learning new things,
I probably would've been in
the game for as long as I was.
Hi, I'm so thematic to everything
you've been able to discuss today.
Did you ever have a situation in your
career where you felt disconnected from
the things that brought you and
kept you in the sport and if so,
how did you recognize it? Disconnect?
How did you identify that was happening?
I talk about a lot of these concepts and
a lot of things that have sustained me.
I mean, goodness, I like,
I wrote a book about it,
but there's,
you just never arrive in life and
there's so many times where I have to be
willing to examine my heart in situations
where I maybe didn't find my inner
world as well developed as I hoped were.
Maybe jealousy popped up.
Maybe I want it to be right.
Maybe I want to have an excuse and
the way that I was able to really,
you have to be okay not having it all
together. You just, you never master it.
You have to be willing
to be a work in progress.
And when I found myself maybe not
operating the way that I wanted to,
maybe on a feeling really threatened
all of the sudden, and I'm like, wow,
I thought I had that figured out.
I thought I looked at everything as an
opportunity and I, I was killing it. Um,
I actually really pulled on other people.
So being in community and allowing
people into your process was really,
really healthy. Um, I
think we have the idea,
especially in sports where,
I mean in,
in all of culture,
we,
we champion a self made millionaires.
We say when you're isolated, when you came
from nothing and now you're something,
um,
I think you can be successful,
but it's not very fulfilling
doing it that way. Um,
and letting people in behind every great
athlete is a team of great people. Um,
there's no self made millionaires
in the athletic world.
And every time that I failed,
messed up felt like I
learned this lesson long ago,
but I was relearning it
for the hundredth time. Um,
it was my coaches and it was
people who believed in me. Um,
on the days that I
didn't believe in myself.
So first of all, thanks for coming
in, fixing things or to talk. Um,
my question is like, you know,
now looking back, you know,
after having gone for your career,
if you were to look back and talk
to the 14 year old you who were,
was dreaming at the time and how
things have changed since then,
what type of advice and recommendation
would you give them but you didn't
necessarily have back then?
Honestly,
the,
the most important thing that I've ever
learned in my snowboarding careers at
identity thing,
um,
I think not a lot of people get
to reach the top of something.
Most of the time,
life is a journey and all of a sudden
I was 18 years old and I won the,
I won the x games,
the Olympics in the u s
open all in the same season.
I'd accomplished everything
I ever wanted to do.
And I just had equated that
success meant that I was fulfilled.
And at a really young age, I had to
figure that out. I was like, wow,
this isn't what life's about.
My life is not complete because
I accomplished a list of to do's.
I had to develop a strong
sense of self outside of that.
And in the sports world
you just see it so plainly,
there's such a level of insecurity
and performance culture that is just
unsettling.
And so when I look at the young girl says,
that's the number one thing
that I say young athletes,
hey you got to figure this part out
before you can navigate this really well.
Cause it just, it just makes it, um,
it just doesn't make it fun when it,
there's so much more freedom and so much
more enjoyment when you can sort that
identity piece out.
Uh, three mountains to
snowboard. What'd you say? Oh,
what's your top three
months in system board?
Um,
I lived in mammoth California
forever and I love that resort.
They do a great job kind of maintaining
their terrain parks and then they get
like, um, 300 days of Sun.
And when it's not sunny
it's just nuking snow. Um,
that's a great mountain.
Snow mass in Colorado was really fun.
If you like the groomers,
really top notch groomers there.
Um, and then my favorite destination
to go snowboarding would be Japan,
Hokkaido, north island. Japan
is always my number one pick.
He ever get the opportunity to go there.
I would highly recommend it.
Thanks so much for couple of Kelly.
I'm curious just on training routines,
training for an Olympics,
what did a typical day look like and how
did that change over the course of your
career?
Yeah, that's a great question. Um,
well, like I referenced before,
Snow Morning Really wasn't a
sport when I started and um,
there's so much kind of lifestyle and um,
easygoingness attached to it.
And I remember in 2010 I had
been to three Olympic Games,
I had two Olympic metals and
the US snowboard team said, hey,
would you like to come
in for fitness testing?
Like it just wasn't even on our radar
before then. We're not like real athletes,
you know? And so, um, I was like,
yeah, sure, that sounds good. I'll,
I could, you know, do some
high jumps for ya or whatever.
And I did it. And I was like, Hey,
what, what do I, what am I results mean?
And I'm my trainer to this day,
still bring this up.
Every once in a while she says,
wow, you are really mentally,
it must be really mentally
strong. And I was like, wait,
it's a fitness test.
Like that's like telling someone they
have a nice personality. You're like,
you're, you're beautiful on the inside,
you know? And I'm like, seriously?
And then she was like, yeah,
like it's pretty incredible.
We've been able to accomplish.
And I'm like, what?
And hence all this like inner personal
inner world development, you know?
Um,
but I could have either been
really offended or looked
at it as an opportunity.
And I said, you know what?
This is an untapped resource.
So in 2010 and I said, hey,
let's figure out what it looks like to
train a snowboarder. We don't even know.
There's no data. We know how to train
baseball players and football players and,
but we don't know what does it look
like for ideal body comps in different
things. So we, I could, I was like,
I give you four years and in those four
years when I was mentioning like kind of
my peak of my year of my career,
um,
I went up to winning 86% of the contest
I entered and my consistency and my
durability went through the roof. And, um,
I was the only one on the US team and
four year span who didn't require surgery
and I was older than everybody and
I was just like, oh my goodness,
this is a incredible resource. And so, um,
that was a big part of the
second part of my career.
And heading into this last Olympics,
I think I was logging 22 to 24 hours of
dry land training week and it's a lot
of, we lightened lien is
what we would train for.
We'd have two days of cardio.
Um,
we'd have two days of strength
training, three days of core, um,
and they would kind of overlap over
a six day span with one day off.
So lightened lean, a lot of stability
stuff, lot of body weight stuff.
Um, I can get more into detail after it,
but it's, it's kind of a work in progress.
And we would profile my body comps when
I would perform really well and we'd
start to discover, okay, so I'm performing
my best on my body, looks like this.
Okay. Let, that's our target like
we were starting from scratch. So
thanks for coming. Thanks for everything
you've done for this board. Um,
my question is being a woman snowboarder,
um,
was there a point where you realize that
you are not only a champion for this
snowboarding asset sport as a whole but
for women borders and then becoming a
household name as a
woman athlete? Um, yeah,
you know, in snowboarding
there is not, um,
the different size ball that we play with.
We are,
we're on the same kind of
venue as the guys. And, uh,
when, when I was growing up, I was
one girl kind of in a pack of guys.
And um,
I got on the u s team and I found kind
of a crew of girls to ride with. And,
um,
there was people who went before me that
really inspired me and that I looked up
to a,
I remember waiting in line to get
people's autographs at the u s open.
And then I found myself having little
kids waiting in line to get autographs at
the u s open when I was
18. And I thought, Gosh,
I'm in a position to be
able to inspire people. Um,
and that's kind of how I looked at it.
I thought I have a responsibility
and an opportunity to,
to impact people in a positive way. And
I just looked at it as a privilege and,
um, I tried to do my
best knowing that, um,
I really had a lot of influence and,
um,
you know,
there's not a ton of,
I think at Burton we have a woman CEO
and she's been an advocate for women and
for everything from equal prize money to,
um,
women in leadership at the
company, uh, for a very long time.
And so we didn't see it as a huge kind
of contrast between the men and women
because I think I was so close to it and
our leadership was always empowering to
women.
It just kind of seemed natural and normal.
When I kind of grew up a
bit and saw other sports,
I realized how unique
snowboarding actually was. Um,
so I just tried to,
to make sure that I was always,
uh, I guess the same person too. I think
anytime you're in a place of influence,
you want,
you want to be the same person that you
are when you're winning or losing at the
top of the hill,
at the bottom of the hill when you're
home with your friends and when you're
with your family. And so I strive
to live a life of consistency, um,
and authenticity because I think that's
a huge attribute and snowboarding that
we have a huge value for.
And, um, I think it's,
it's been a cool journey to see the sport
grow, especially with the young women.
Again,
sort of like a question about how you
deal with challenges and like when you
take these massive slams,
you touched on this a little bit,
but was wondering if you could go to a
little bit more detail about what do you
really thinking about,
like how do you actually get yourself
to like come over that hurdle right then
and get yourself up and go again?
Um, my coach has a saying, uh,
it's, uh, if it was easy
everybody would be doing it.
And um,
I heard that often at the top of
the pipe when I was discouraged.
Um,
you know,
I kind of always had an idea that nothing
was impossible and I wouldn't let my
circumstances decide things for me.
So even when I did take those big crashes,
when I did take those big falls,
it was a mix of,
of personal drive and then
people believing in me and
speaking into me as well.
It was those coaches,
it was those friends.
It was the people being willing to ask
for help and not have it together all the
time and being willing to be challenged
and fail to know that eventually you,
uh, what does it, uh,
Thomas Edison, you know,
we just learned a bunch of ways
not to make a light bulb, you know,
using all those failures as like,
wow though in one way not to do it,
I guess I should try again.
And you want to stay, you know,
snowboarding especially it's,
it's a high impact sport and you want to
stay within your ability level when you
take this and you want to be
realistic. And so, you know,
in document my coaches do you
think deserves a realistic
trick for me to work on
and what kind of steps am I going
to need to take to get there?
And not everything's instant.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
getting strong enough to take those risks,
especially as I got older in my
career was really helpful as well.
So I knew if it didn't go well,
most likely I would bounce.
Hopefully I would bounce.
I was kind of, my plan
was a good plan or not.
Was there a specific trick or anything
else that made you more nervous than
usual before run or an event?
Um,
typically your most difficult
run or you're your most
difficult trick is the one
you think about, but it's kind
of a catch 22 because, um,
you really can only focus
on one thing at a time.
I remember we had a sports psychologist
come by our team one time and he gave us
two tennis balls.
One guy was supposed to throw it up and
down really quickly and the other one
was supposed to be thrown across the room
and we were told to keep track of how
many times each tennis ball was thrown.
After about 20 seconds, he said,
would you come up with, and we're like,
ah, we all lost count. And I said,
that's the point. And you can't focus
on two things at the same time. Um,
and my 10 80 was probably
my hardest trick.
But if I was thinking about doing a 10
80 on my third hit when I dropped in for
my first hit guarantee you I would
fall first, hit on a straighter.
So you know,
you want to anticipate those things,
but by the time you get to those events,
by the time you get to the Olympics,
like you should have it figured out.
Those are muscle memory things.
It's not something that
they can be intimidating,
but it's not going to be something
you're going to have to think your way
through.
Your body knows what to do by that time.
And it was really a battle to,
um,
really just stay on the task
at hand or in the moment.
Uh,
I remember I was hiking up,
one of my friends that I snowboard with,
I snowboarded with for a long time.
She had the same coach and she was
talking through her run with Ricky and my
coach. And it's, it's gonna look
like this. I've got to do this,
I've got to do this. And then I've
got to look here on this, on this. Uh,
I've got to be careful to keep my speed
and that, and I'm like, listen to her.
Like, Whoa, that's a lot. And Rick,
he looks at me and he says, Hey,
what are you going to do kid? I
said, I'm going to do a good drop in.
And they just looked at me and they
just laughed at like, seriously?
That's your plan. I'm like, totally,
everything else is, I know how to do it.
I just have to make sure I get in there.
And so it's a fine line between being
prepared and then in the moment,
actually letting your body know what it
knows how to do. Thanks so much Kelly.
Thank you very much guys.
Another round of applause. Maybe.